[Music]
good evening and welcome to the LAN
focused Channel this is a quick video to
bring you some breaking news from the
linguistic world according to recently
released documents the European Union
will soon be adopting Esperanto as an
official language for those who don't
know Esperanto is a constructed language
that was created in the 1870s by dr. ll
Zalman Haas it was created in order to
function as an international auxiliary
language that people all around the
world can learn and it was intentionally
designed to be extremely easy to learn
but Esperanto never fully caught on and
remained mostly a hobby for language
nerds until now according to EU
officials Esperanto will be designated
the 25th official language of the
European Union and will function as a
working language of the European
Parliament as well as a procedural
language of the European Commission in
addition to English French and German
the EU is also expected to soon
recommend that all Member States begin
drafting plans for public school
educational programs in Esperanto the
unofficial word on the street is that
with the coming departure of the UK from
the European Union enthusiasm for
learning English is declining and
Esperanto is a viable long-term option
to replace English as the international
language this new European Union policy
will begin on April 31st 2017 this is
wonderful news for Esperanto lovers all
around the world the Esperanto dream of
uniting the world with one language is
one step closer please leave your
comments in support of Esperanto in the
comment section down below and show your
support for this European Union
initiative thank you for tuning in for
this important breaking news line focus
we'll be back with a regular video very
soon thank you for watching and have a
nice stay
[Music]
you
[Music]